hey what's up everybody i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
and today is september 27th
2021 i am back in studio after a week in
new york city
i was catching up on some family stuff
it was actually the first time that my
entire family meeting my folks my
brother my sister their wives husbands
kids nieces nephews it was the first
time that we all got together
as one family physically in the same
place since february of 2020 right
before the lockdown and uh it was long
overdue and well needed so i appreciate
you guys bearing with me uh despite no
shows
last week but i can tell you that going
forward for the rest of the year we're
back to like a completely normal
schedule i have one or two little travel
things that will pop up but we're back
here five days a week eleven o'clock
pacific which is right now uh today guys
uh got a few things i want to talk about
not going to do much on uh covid and i
had a little revelation about that uh
which i'll i'll get to in just a sec but
the three things that we're going to be
covering uh today are this potato man
you know this potato guy mr potato head
over on
cnn he has a show called reliable
sources which as i often tell you it's
the most ironically named show in the
history of television it should be
called unreliable sources and then i
would never have to talk about it
because it would be what it is and it
would be sort of pointless uh well uh
brian stelter yeah that's the guy he's
the host uh they're just getting worse
and worse over there he's supposed to be
a media watchdog and he's actually like
basically the chief propagandist of cnn
at this point so we're gonna show a
little clip from his show yesterday uh
then something that you're really not
gonna see on on his network of cnn
they're not doing much talking about
this we have an absolute disastrous
crisis at the border right now at our
texas texas mexico border i mean there
are just thousands and thousands of
people flooding in we're going to show
you some video
and then we're going to show you some
uh some chat between uh fox news's chris
wallace and uh who is it it is our
uh
it's our who's the guy uh oh it's our
department of homeland security
secretary uh majorcas he was on fox news
yesterday trying to explain why we're
letting people in and how many people
were letting in and i think you're going
to see
that he doesn't quite know what he's
talking about and then finally the
democrats passed a really really really
extreme federal abortion law
yesterday um or over the weekend it i
mean it's really really quite extreme
and we'll get to that i mean basically
abortions up until birth and then you
know we've talked before about
post-birth abortions uh before we get to
any of that though i want to talk about
two things real quick so i was in new
york city for the week and then i was in
long island
and i hadn't been back to new york city
well i was actually in new york city
once since this all began at the
debut night of gutfeld way back in april
and i was really shocked how sort of new
york city seemed like a ghost town and i
have to say that being back i was
shocked again because this time i was
shocked how open the city was
for sure midtown where normally you know
you've got the huge buildings and the
hustle and bustle of new york city in
the city that never sleeps and all that
midtown was you know still somewhat
quiet but most of the residential areas
people were out and about very few
people were wearing masks restaurants
were open almost every restaurant now
has an outdoor
little basically they've built sort of
bungalows outside sort of on the street
but people were indoors people were
outdoors you know they have this thing
now where you have to show the vaccine
passport if you walk into stores but
many stores i walked into nobody asked
me for a vaccine passport nobody asked
me to put on a mask i went down to
chinatown i went down to little italy
they were jam-packed and people were
happy and smiling and the weather was
great and i mentioned all of this
because you know as you know for now i
am here in los angeles and i was
actually stop uh shocked at the stark
difference between los angeles and new
york city new york city still has like a
fighting spirit to it and people are out
and about living their lives and again
if you want to wear a mask you can wear
them asking it you don't you don't okay
it's all good um
so i was like actually pleasantly
surprised which was which was very weird
so i just wanted to mention that because
you know we we talk about all these
stories about how horrible the
conditions are in a lot of these cities
and yes there was plenty of homelessness
in new york city and yes i saw someone
shooting up basically on 34th and 7th
pretty close to
penn station and you know with the
cities dirty and there's police
everywhere and all that but the general
tenor of people being out and about and
just kind of living was pretty good does
it have a whole bunch of other problems
that are probably only going to get
worse uh because of the amount of
progressives there yes but just that
people were there uh i thought was
pretty good one other real real quick
thing and then we're gonna get to uh to
all the stories
uh so i was at home at my parents and uh
my dad said to me he was sitting at the
computer i was sitting in the room and
he said he said you know you gotta look
at this i keep getting all these emails
from twitter and they're always showing
me things that are from people who don't
like you or things that are literally me
or people you know things that you
disagree with or a whole bunch of weird
stuff so i said that i didn't even know
you were on twitter he said i don't
think i am on twitter i said let me see
the email so i look at his email and he
does have an email from twitter and it
says he has an account he said he was
like oh maybe i did make a twitter
account years ago but i never go on
twitter i looked at his phone he doesn't
have the twitter app on his phone he
doesn't have the app on his desktop over
there never goes on twitter wasn't even
sure he had an account
and i said all right well let's figure
this out so we sign into we figure out
what email it corresponded to we sign
into his twitter account okay he did
create a twitter account about four
years ago he follows nobody
zero people this is not white power
people i i just gave it i gave it to
media matters my
there you go media matters uh he follows
zero people turns out he has three
followers they were all we checked they
were three people that he knows that
somehow found his account but he follows
your people and i look at his feed
and his feed is all like crazy lefty
progressive things and literally
youtubers that hate me and the entire
feed is filled with all this yet he
follows no people so we click over to
some of the accounts that he's
supposedly following because they're in
his feed even though it says he has zero
things that he's following zero accounts
he's following and he is following them
he is following them so i was like this
is very weird it says you follow zero
people you never use
twitter they're sending you constantly
emails that are seemingly always against
me and for progressive causes and
everything else this doesn't make any
sense so then we were just looking
around his account it turns out that he
one time
about four years ago liked a tweet from
me that's the only tweet he's ever liked
he liked a tweet from me it was when i
was once on a show with larry king and i
said he was the best interviewer ever my
dad apparently liked that tweet and then
somehow
through the twitter algorithm they
figured out a way
to have him follow lefty accounts even
though he never clicked follow on any of
them fill his feed with that and then
send him emails about that stuff for
four years even though the one thing
that he ever liked or interacted with at
twitter.com
was something that i had tweeted out
anyway i say all of this to say
man they are screwing with us in ways we
cannot imagine we know plenty of ways
that they are with de-boosting and
shadow banning and algorithmic tricks
and making you watch certain things and
hiding other things and reordering
search results and all that stuff we
know all about that
but in this case my own dad being
force-fed videos
that are either about me negatively or
just filled with stuff that i wouldn't
talk about
and then having him follow these
accounts of course i did
tag jack dorsey on twitter and asked him
about it he did not respond
um but i got to tell you guys i i really
think my my time on twitter is limited
because they are they are evil at this
point i don't know how we can say
anything other than the way they are
manipulating us just think if that's
just one little instance with my dad
just think how all of us
could be getting hit with emails and
things we don't follow in search results
and all that to actually change how we
think about things
i mean really think about it what they
could possibly be doing it's
bananas as i often say all right guys
let's get to the stories but before that
i want to talk to you about american
hartford gold you know i'm sure i'm not
the only one who's noticed everything is
getting expensive ain't it the truth and
with all this printing and spending by
our government i'm concerned the
dollar's end is near if the government
continues it's out of control printing
and spending the dollar could continue
its freefall and lose its coveted role
as the world reserve currency many
believe that we'll see dark days ahead
for the dollar that's why now more than
ever i recommend you diversify
your accounts with gold and silver and
the company i recommend is american
hartford gold they sell physical gold
and silver delivered right to your door
inside of your ira and they make it easy
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they'll give you up to fifteen
hundred dollars of free silver on your
first order so don't wait give them a
call that's eight six six two one nine
ninety three eleven that's eight six six
two one nine nine three one one or text
reuben to six five five three two again
it's eight six six two one nine ninety
three eleven or text reuben to six five
five three two and now back to me all
right you know i often talk to you guys
about how we should deal with the liars
should we constantly expose the liars
should we ignore the liars is there a
gulag for the liars what are we supposed
to do i'm not sure that i have an answer
that i love yet so for now my main
answer is that we must expose these
people relentlessly and while at the
same time building better products and
figuring out what it is that we all
believe but for now we have to expose
them because
unfortunately they have a
disproportionate amount of power and an
awful lot of people who believe them one
of the prime purveyors of lies is cnn's
brian stelter
and you know what i won't lead any
further here's his show yesterday right
again he lays out one of these you know
exactly what you're describing how it
could all happen in 2024 it is it is
quite unnerving and and you say there's
some cowards out there that don't want
to talk about it what do folks in the
reality-based media do in the coming
weeks what's your advice for the press
corps
i mean my my advice for the press corps
is to make to is to is to drop the the
fair and balanced about the one party
and the other party who cares about the
parties right the parties aren't really
the story the story is whether we have a
democracy or not and the behavior of the
parties is is is the actual story i mean
so i think that the main the main thing
we have to do and and you guys have done
a lot in this direction is to drop the
pretense of american exceptionalism drop
the idea that democracy is just out
there like the air we breathe and make
democracy the story itself we had we had
minimal excuse to be surprised by 2016.
we had no excuse to be surprised by the
coup attempt in 2020 and if we're not
prepared for an attempt for people to
take power undemocratically in in 2024
then we're just at this point
pathetically naive preparing for that
and getting the facts out so that people
can prepare for that and prevent it is
is what you know colleagues in
journalism journalism should be doing
all right in just a second i'll get to
everything that his guest that law
professor said there's a lot of nonsense
there but uh if you saw the chiron there
that's the little banner there that they
put the little you know the headline of
the story it said right wing media is a
safe space for liars well stelter you're
not going to believe this on the
internet we can clip things that you've
done and show them take a look so
disappointing to look at what we're
seeing from right media these days where
there's such an obsession with the deep
state and these revelations about the
russia probe
latest on the robert mueller russia
investigation mueller investigation the
russian investigation trump's russia
ties and robert mueller the real russia
story russia probe the ongoing russia
probe russia probe the russian
investigation but mueller and the russia
russia synergies they wonder if russia
has compromising information on the
president what is the source for the
president's claim that they have found
no collusion with russia he misspelled
collusion every day we're trying to keep
track of the drip drip drip of the
russia investigation drip drip drip drip
drip drip drip drip drip drip trip trump
and russia to see whether trump was
secretly working for russia bring it
back to russia and russia russia russia
russia russia russia russia russia
russia russia russia russia robert
mueller robert mueller special counsel
robert mueller robert mueller robert
mueller robert mueller robert mueller
robert mueller mueller investigation
mueller report russia conspiracy do you
believe that he's colluding with russia
i wish i could just say no he's
definitely not that's crazy
russia russia russia
believe me when i tell you that was just
one of many compilations of sort of
fabricated half-assed stories that mr
potato head over there has been pushing
on the rapidly decreasing viewers of cnn
but unfortunately some of the people
that watch it have a certain amount of
influence so
who is putting misinformation out there
pretending that trump was colluding with
russia and stole the election remember
that was what they ran with for four
years so i guess that guy works for the
safe space of cnn it's a left-wing
misinformation outlet or something to
that effect but now let's get to the
content of what his guest said there his
guest who is a law professor by the way
and an author um he says that cnn should
not be uh impartial well in that regard
uh he's i guess telling them what
they're doing because they're obviously
not impartial so he must be feeling good
about that we have to drop american
exceptionalism i mean that's his opinion
but i don't know why we would do that
you know there's thousands of people
trying to storm our borders right now
because they still want to live here
despite the fact that everyone says how
horrible we are so maybe america's still
even in this hampered you know sort of
kneecapped broken leg state that we're
in maybe we are kind of exceptional
still and then of course he talks about
the coup attempt you know the coup
attempt where nobody brought a gun uh
the coup attempt that there were no
plans to take over the government the
coup attempt that was done in three
hours and the coup attempt that you know
really wasn't a coup or any of that
stuff these people are maniacs like i
don't know what we can do with these
people like you know like i don't want
to put them in the gulag i know they'd
love to put all of us in the blog but at
what point
do we have to have like a real national
conversation i mean everything that he's
saying there is a lie
what's dealt like he's doing that
segment to make it seem like if you
don't believe what he says you're a bad
person or you've suffered from
misinformation or you're a liar you know
you're of course you're a right-wing
maniac everything else and the problem
is a certain amount of people believe
that now look i suppose you guys
watching this you know you you don't
believe that but that means they're
talking about you
right they're not just talking about me
they're talking about you so we we need
to figure out how we're going to take
these
two
it's not two truths you have one thing
that's true and then you have one
nonsensical thing and they exist in the
same universe and how do we mesh these
things to have sort of a cohesive
cohesive world view as as an american
right like it's gonna get tougher and
tougher and tougher these people are
never they've gone in so deep remember
half the country used to be racists now
half the country's racists who also are
sick and trying to kill you and kill
your grandma and everything else so it's
like basically at this point if stelter
says something maybe we should start
doing a segment on the show if stelter
says something the opposite is true
let's just get like a whole list of
times that he he's done that and by the
way it's not just him it's it's lamin
it's cuomo it's the rest of the clowns
on that on that show
or on that network who often appear on
that show all right i think i think i
made my point all right i think i did
guys let's talk about start mail real
quick you know free email services like
gmail and yahoo aren't really free you
pay with your privacy internet giants
bank on exploiting your data by selling
it to the highest bidder your business
plan google has it your medical records
yahoo can sell them to drug companies
personally i don't want to open myself
up to identity theft and i can't imagine
you do either that's why i suggest using
start mail it makes email safe again
start mail keeps email private period
when you delete an email in start mail
it's gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazon's which
means they can't be put out of business
like parlor switching to start mail is
seamless too you can easily transfer all
of your current email data so there's no
starting from scratch you get unlimited
anonymous aliases this feature protects
your main email address from spam and
phishing attacks so that people can't
sell your information and they can be
deleted at any time i keep saying the
way to forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value the service
start mail provides your cyber security
has never been more at risk take control
of your privacy with start mail before
it's too late start securing your email
privacy with start mail sign up today
and you'll get 50 off your first year go
to start mail.com reuben that's start
with t s-t-a-r-t mail.com reuben for
fifty percent off your first year start
mail.com reuben
and now back to me uh all right so uh
you know if you watch the uh the cnn uh
network that we were just talking about
you're not going to see much about the
border right and if you open up the new
york times you're not going to see much
about the border and if you read the new
york the washington post or watch msnbc
or all of these things you're not going
to see much about the border because
there is a crisis at the border and we
have a democrat administration
and you know because they're kind of in
cahoots right the media and the
democrats are in cahoots like if you
don't see that at this point i don't
know what to tell you
when things aren't going well they're
always going to run cover for it and of
course if there were thousands of people
flooding our borders and say trump or
another republican was president they
would be telling us all sorts of crazy
things right this would they would be
leading the story the incompetency of
the trump administration they'd be
mocking him for not building the wall
etc etc etc well right now we've got
literally thousands and thousands of
people
at our border with texas basically fox
news has been the only one covering this
and then
was it the department of uh department
of homeland security they actually
stopped drones from being flown at the
border they made it illegal however they
whatever i don't know if they make it
illegal whatever edict they can pass
because too many people were flying
drones showing video of people basically
swarming the border so you said they
said you can't do that anymore fox
actually figured out a way to get some
cameras at the border and we're seeing
thousands of people and in this case
we're talking mostly about haitians who
are coming through our mexican border
right it's not mexicans even coming
through it's haitians that somehow get
to mexico and they're flooding our
border we're going to show you some
video of that in just a second
but department of homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas was on fox
news yesterday talking about the border
crisis and if you want to watch a man
waffle here you go
i want to start with those 30 000
haitian migrants who came across the
border into del rio texas since
september ninth as you say
you say that twelve thousand four
hundred will have their cases heard by
an immigration judge and another five
thousand are being processed by your
department
mr secretary of those seventeen thousand
four hundred
how many have been released into the u s
and how many more potentially could be
released into the u s so chris um uh
about three thousand are actually in
detention uh and we make those detention
determinations in the best interest of
the american public others are in
immigration court proceedings they are
monitored by us we impose conditions uh
upon them so we
keep in touch with them and ensure their
appearance in court as the law requires
but to answer my question directly of
the 17 400 that weren't deported back or
didn't return on their own to mexico how
many of them either
well first how many have been released
into the u.s uh they're released on
conditions and approximately i think
it's about 10 000 or so 12 000 have been
released yes and of the five thousand
are still in process
we will uh make determinations whether
they will be uh returned
uh to uh haiti uh based on our public
health and public interest
authorities
so when we talk about a total of 12 000
or could it be even higher it could it
could be even higher
it could be even higher first off he
goes oh yeah 10 000 are in then a second
later he's like twelve thousand and then
he ends it by saying yeah it could be
even higher now i don't wanna make this
about haitians but at the moment i am
told we are in some sort of pandemic
have you heard about this where people
are wearing masks all the time and
getting endless shots for something so
you'd think at a time like this we might
if we were a serious country we might be
like you know guys we got to kind of
shut down our borders figure out what's
going on in our house i'm actually not
even fully calling for this but i'm just
saying like it would be a rational
situation think about it as your own
home right like if there were zombies
coming to your house you might say uh
hey we gotta close our doors make sure
we got food make sure everybody here is
okay and then we can deal with you know
maybe helping the zombies in the sort of
i am legend type situation right we can
all will smith it after that
but in the midst of the pandemic we now
have we're being told 12 000 and he's
saying maybe more haitians that have
basically just walked into the country
now we're going to show you some video
in just a second and and while we were
playing that i was told that the way fox
got the video that we'll show you in a
few in just a minute or two uh was that
the local sheriff allowed fox to take
video after the department of homeland
security basically said nobody can take
video anymore but the sheriffs who are
on the ground having to deal with this
lunacy from the federal government
basically they want people to be able to
see what's happening so we have 12 000
maybe more people just coming into the
country right now do we know what these
people believe do they believe in
american values are they going to have
jobs here do they have family members
here where are they going to live notice
the government really never tells us
about any of that stuff we're just we're
so good even though we're actually so
evil because we're systematically racist
in the whole thing but we're so good
just come on in and bring covet and
bring homelessness and potentially other
disease and the rest of it i mean it's
just sheer nonsense but we've got a
little bit more i believe from mayorkus
take a look why did you allow them in
the country in the first place why
didn't you build
forgive me a wall or a fence to stop
them from walking in this flood of
people coming across the dam it looks
like a highway that allows them to cross
the rio grande it is this the policy of
this administration uh we do not agree
with the building of the wall the law
provides that individuals can make a
claim for humanitarian relief that is
actually one of our proudest traditions
all right
again we're going to show you some video
in just a second but i like what he says
there it's the policy not to agree with
the wall
well that's not a policy that's just
something you don't agree with what is
your policy that we're just going to
allow people to come here no matter who
you are we're not going to ask much
we're in the middle of a pandemic and
you can just rampage through the border
and run through the border and by the
way they don't social distance and they
don't have mass and everything else ah
video
go so we're just showing you some video
here it's about a minute long i thought
i'd do a little play-by-play that's the
bridge where a lot of people hang out in
tents and stuff they get over there this
is at the texas border you can see
people just wandering just wandering
around people strolling into america how
you doing america what's going on uh
from what i can tell and let me let me
get a little bit of a closer look here
it looks like some of the people in that
group right there to the right of the
bridge connor do those people seem
socially distanced is that is that an la
that looks like an la homeless shelter
under the bridge right here near where i
live
so they come and you know we again we
don't know do they have jobs do they
have family members here but we
literally are letting thousands and
thousands of these people in and just to
be clear one more time this has nothing
to do with racism or anything else every
country exists to have borders every
country exists to say you are a citizen
you are not a citizen it is not a policy
to say we don't agree with the wall
that's not a policy would a wall
potentially stop people from coming in
yeah you know you're walking down the
street then there's a wall you might
have to go this way and then there's a
wall over here you might and then
eventually you might turn around
and again that is also not to say that
there aren't legit humanitarian reasons
but we cannot especially right now when
our country is a freaking
mess okay
food prices going up the economy is is
just like wobbling around house prices
going up we know homelessness i mean
these people are all going to go to big
cities and then what happens in big
cities we get more homelessness we get
more drug use we get more crime all of
those things and then you know you
wouldn't want to arrest any of these
people who are committing crimes or
doing drugs or any of that because then
you'd be racist so we got a big problem
on our hands and all all the democrats
have and i don't mean to make this a
partisan thing because again it's not
like it's not like the republicans are
so great about anything
but at this point it's like all the
democrats have is if you don't do what
we want when you want us to do it you're
a racist well if having a border
and being able to make honest decisions
and have having conversations that we're
supposed to have as a nation about who
can be here who can't whether you have
to follow the laws whether we have laws
uh if that makes me a racist then i
guess i'm a racist but i'm pretty sure
that's not the definition of racism but
you know definitions of words are always
changing these days real quick so it's
possible it happened during the show
i'll check all right guys we've got one
more for you uh this is this is really
bizarre what happened in the last couple
days
on this democrat caucus
which voted the democrat house caucus
which voted 218
to one in favor of a federal law
enshrining a right to abortion through
all nine months of pregnancy we've got
some images here from cnn as i'm talking
the congressional democrats abortion
bill would require that all 50 states
allow abortion after viability until
birth if a loan health care provider
determines the pregnancy poses a risk to
the parents uh to the pregnant patient's
mental health okay so there's a couple
things we have to talk about here now
first off i want to preface this all by
saying this is where i get
more pushback than on anything else from
my conservative and right leading
audience although i do have to say
without question it's always done
respectfully and thoughtfully uh as you
guys know in the book it's right there
it's right behind me uh
and don't burn this book i lay out my
position on on every political
issue of our time and the most difficult
section to write was about abortion
because it brings up existential issues
it brings up philosophical issues and
religious issues and scientific issues
and it brings up legal issues i mean
there's i found it to be the most
difficult to write it was the only it
was actually the only chapter in the
book that i asked for any help from from
anyone and i had like a lot of
interesting conversations uh not only
with with david but with candace owens
and with ben shapiro and and dennis
prager and i talked to
several pro-choice people and i talked
to my sister i mean a whole bunch of
people my position on abortion is that i
acknowledge that when the sperm meets
the egg it's life i do i know it we're
in the midst of surrogacy right now okay
i know that when the sperm eats the egg
and then the next thing you got a
blastocyst and you got an embryo it's
like it has to start somewhere it
doesn't just magically start when you
want it to start i i acknowledge that i
also acknowledge that in a pluralistic
society where people have all sorts of
beliefs and all sorts of religious views
and all of those things you want to give
the maximum amount of freedom to the
maximum amount of people i also don't
want the government making decisions for
people so that's why this is so complex
so i get i completely get the the
pro-life position which is conception
it's a life we have to protect life now
what the conservatives and the
right-leaning people don't do that well
on this is okay if you're gonna say
women you cannot get an abortion well
are you gonna help that woman during
those nine months of pregnancy are you
gonna help that woman once the baby is
born and are you gonna fund things and
everything else do you want the
government to do that because you
usually don't want the government do
that so you're going to put that all on
private uh you know churches and temples
and things of that nature nonprofits
we don't really have that discussion
that often but i've discussed this on
the show you could watch some of my
previous interviews with ben shapiro and
dennis prager and other people that are
pro-life
what i've said to them
is that it's not that their arguments on
abortion have made me sort of more
uh i don't want to say anti-choice but
more pro-life it's that the left has
gone so bananas with this
like they do with everything everything
without exception that that is what has
made me more pro-life so i used to say
20 weeks 20 weeks used to be the
position where you know doctors
basically said the fetus could feel pain
and i felt that that was a bridge too
far and then of course we can talk about
you know exemptions related to direct
health physical health of the mother
interestingly in this bill that the
democrats just passed 218 to one if you
heard the last sentence that i said
there it's now about posing a risk to
the pregnant patient's mental health
mental health yeah that's very different
than physical health and you only need
one health care provider to say it so
you literally could just find a nurse
you could find a friend who's a nurse
and you could be seven months pregnant
and be like ah i just i'm not in the
mood to do this anymore i'm kind of
depressed and it's like abortion time
that's literally what this will lead to
so this is this is just
messy all over the place okay it's messy
all over the place but as i've said to
shapiro and prager and some of my other
and glenn beck some of my other pro-life
friends it's that it's not that their
arguments are so convincing to me right
because i want the state out of the way
and i want people to be able to make
choices for themselves and and we can
discuss the life or death situation all
that it's that the left goes so crazy
with it that it's like man i don't want
these people near any decision related
to a woman a man or a child or anyone
else if you think that eight month
abortions are okay if you think that
five-month abortions are okay
like you need to be examined and again
we can talk about the exemptions we can
talk about when there's a true risk to
that woman's health we can talk about
when there is a horrific genetic disease
that that that child will never be able
to live a fully actualized life like we
could have all if we could if you guys
weren't so nuts about everything we
could honestly have those discussions
again that's what a healthy society
would do right is the same thing as the
border story we just covered in a
healthy society you would take a complex
topic we want to be open and pluralistic
and allow people to come here and we're
a nation of immigrants but we can't let
everybody in but you can't even have
that because you're racist and in this
case if you have the honest discussion
about
when does life begin what should a
society do do you want the government
making decisions for women blah blah
blah blah
and for the baby uh you know you're
either you either hate women or you hate
babies or the rest of it so we got to
get better at some of this stuff i think
that's the theme for this monday's show
is we got to get a little better at
discussing some of this stuff i'm going
to keep trying to do that and i think
you will do it along with me by the way
guys uh just in the last couple weeks
we've started doing live chat
in the locals community during this live
stream we're now doing it every day of
the week so if you join us at
reubenreport.locals.com you can chat
without bots without haters without
general psychotic lunatics of the
internet with actual real people you can
have a live chat uh during the show and
we're working to expand that in in a
couple ways that hopefully i can let you
know about in the next little while so
uh do join us over there uh my interview
with jason whitlock
from blaze tvs fearless is up right now
the clips really took off full episode
just went up yesterday uh and my
interview with jack posobiac uh will be
coming out tomorrow and as i said if you
want a live chat during the show join us
at reubenreport.locals.com
and i'm back people i know that
september has been a little uh a little
helter skelter here we had some holidays
early and then i had this week to new
york but we're fully back i'm excited to
be back in studio a lot of good stuff's
cooking i'll have some some other
announcements i'm pretty good about
leading you guys with announcements that
good stuff's coming and then pretty much
always come through we got we got some
good stuff cooking over the next couple
weeks i'll have a couple announcements
on that front anyway it's monday have a
great week and we'll be back tomorrow
you